when we first started looking into the
Kowloon wall City also known as the
densest city in the world we thought for
a place that's essentially a slum full
of crime drugs with sub-human living
conditions there sure is a lot of
romanticization about this place in
Japan they even built a giant arcade
that mimics parts of Kowloon and I get
it the city looks like it came straight
out of a dystopian sci-fi novel it's a
giant mega structure part architecture
part living organism and it's actually
something Architects have been dreaming
about for years one continuous structure
where you could access all the
necessities of daily life that evolves
and grows with time but there's also
stories after stories from people who's
lived there or visited there that claim
to have fond memories of this place
describing it as an energetic
industrious Patchwork of chaos with a
strange compelling Beauty
Beauty
how could this possibly be beautiful so
Kowloon wall city was there something
more to this than just chaos
[Music]
a portion of this video sponsored by
millinote
I just want to give you a sense of how
dense it was here's the density of La
New York Hong Kong and Kowloon and it
almost tripled in population in just a
few decades so how did this even happen
Kowloon wall city was a city within Hong
Kong that was technically a part of
China over its lifespan from a small
Chinese military for to this
it was used as a political pawn and the
conflict between China and Britain where
both parties were more interested in
exerting power than actually governing
this piece of land in the end the
tension became unsolvable so both
parties decided to take a hands-off
approach it was left alone and without
any government control or police
presence it just grew and grew almost
like a living organism
buildings were built cheaply and quickly
to accommodate the huge influx of
migrants a massive number of Chinese
refugees flooded here after World War II
as it was known as the only Chinese
Enclave that the Hong Kong government
couldn't touch but after that it
included anyone and everyone from gangs
criminals to doctors to entrepreneurs
people trying to escape poverty or
people trying to capitalize on this
unregulated Haven crime naturally
flourished there with gangs drugs
brothels if you had an industrial
business you could ignore the fire codes
the labor codes or safety codes so you
could produce Goods at a fraction of the
cost you could also sell things that
were banned anywhere else like Dogmeat
with unbeatable prices industry kind of
thrived here and lots of things made in
Kowloon wall City made their way back to
China Hong Kong and sometimes even
overseas they were known as especially
for their fish balls and dumplings
[Music]
the more we learned about the city there
was this idea that kept popping up the
rhizome but it's kind of a complicated
concept so I'll hand it over to Cindy
our researcher and Hong Kong Beat It
foreign
let's try again
to explain we have our Italian filmmaker
actually it's like this plate of pasta
right here since they are so entangled
together you can't really see the
beginning or the end it's like a
decentralized network the loose and
gutari use their rhizome
as a metaphor for a new model of
thinking the cool effects Society
philosophy and culture this could help
us make connections in unexpected ways
what the heck is this science they're
good that's really pretty good Migos
the first rule of the rhizome is that
it's multiple multiplicities without a
structure
let me explain so in a traditional City
you have your city grid and they get
populated with buildings with functions
that are determined by your planning
department you have your circulation at
the base and that's how you get from
here to here but in Kowloon buildings
will get built leaving these small gaps
for air and light but very quickly they
get filled in with stairways which
sometimes connect to two three or four
buildings the city of Kowloon had around
350 buildings but eventually they all
merge into this one giant megastructure
the rooftops will connect forming one
giant rooftop and even the residential
units were connected to each other and
since not all the units had electricity
or other resources it allowed them to
share things like power out of a single
Source it especially allowed businesses
to expand strategically and organically
let's look here for example this is a
strip club but the real money was an
gambling so they connected these
buildings to lure people in with a strip
club and eventually bring them down here
so new buildings could attach and be
integrated to existing structures and
with every new building new circulation
paths and connection points are formed
which evolve and expand with the growth
of the city and at the intersection of
these connections or stairs or alleys
nodes would organically merge here we
see a small convenience store that
serves the people living on the upper
story so they don't have to go all the
way down the city only had a few roads
that created some semblance of order
over here and here we have the
commercial areas because of their direct
connection to the outside it was full of
shops clinics and factories that
naturally gathered on the ground level
Chinese doctors and dentists who
couldn't afford to get re-licensed in
Hong Kong setup shop here and offer
services for bargain prices which
attract customers from outside by the
City Residential units sat on the levels
above and this created some of the most
attractive units in the city thanks to
the daylight this street was called
Huang Ming street directly translating
into light and bright because it would
be lit up at night as drug addicts would
gather here both of these areas had lots
of factories because you could get
vehicle access here and water access
here so food factories naturally
gathered in this area but most of the
residents actually moved through the
hundreds of alleys and secret paths
which all twisted and turned and stepped
up and down and cut through multiple
buildings so unlike a typical City where
you have one point of connection you had
multiple points of connection vertically
and horizontally between multiple spaces
in fact it would be impossible to map
the entire network of the city using
conventional mapping methods
if you've been following this channel
you probably know that we use melano to
organize all of our research from the
early brainstorming session all the way
to the final draft of the research just
having a visual board clarify so many
things and it allows us to make
connections that we didn't really see
before some of our team is remote so
being able to share and edit the boards
real time during our meetings makes our
collaboration very seamless it's kind of
replaced PDFs for us my friends and I
even started planning our trip to Japan
on melanote because you can easily drop
in your map which saves a lot of hassle
when you're planning with more people
it's completely free with no time limits
so you can sign up using the link in the
description so if you can't map it and
without traditional landmarks or views
how do they navigate a city like this
Kowloon generic Romance
satin Kowloon wall City it's a little
risque but there is a recurring theme
memory and Nostalgia here the
protagonist goes to a shop and feels a
certain romantic feeling for her
colleague but the next day she can't
find her way back to the same shop
living here means you need to create
your own unique mental map that's
tailored to your personal experiences
and routines there's not one map of the
city but 33 000 different versions of
Kowloon that evolves and updates just as
a city transforms over time it's
interesting because delusion guitari
also argue that a map should never be a
static representation because that fixes
your thinking about a certain place when
your idea of a thing is fluid and
evolving you can be much more creative
in how you use that thing so in that
sense the city becomes not just a
backdrop but an active participant in
shaping the memories and identities of
the residents
[Music]
but unlike Orizon the Kowloon wall city
has a boundary
a very abrupt boundary so Kowloon wall
City started as a military fort with an
actual wall around it and that's where
the name came from they built this fort
after Britain occupied Hong Kong as a
way to create a visible Chinese military
presence near the new British colony but
during World War II Japan had taken over
swaths of China including Hong Kong and
when they needed building materials to
expand the nearby airport they took the
walls of Calvin wall City and when
Chinese refugees flooded to Hong Kong
after the war they instinctively
gravitated towards the wall City and
even without a physical wall the new
buildings were built almost the same
exact footprint of the original walls
forcing it to expand upwards and inwards
it it's probably also one of the
conditions that forced it to become such
an interconnected City but also what
made a deteriorate so quickly over time
this was the only place in the city
where you could see the sky and get some
fresh air and also the social heart of
the community and in fact even though
they didn't have a government the
residents self-organized to fix problems
as they came up to deal with crime they
formed groups of volunteers to escort
single women and when the Hong Kong
government released plans to demolish
the city they organized the Kowloon City
anti-demolation committee that fought
against the plan for years even the five
Triad gangs organized garbage cleaning
teams and helped settle disputes between
businesses the courtyard was built
around
ayaman the office building from the
ancient military Ford built back in
1845. the building went through multiple
hands from the Christian evangelist
commission where they held schools to
the old people Center but it was
preserved and the courtyard as a whole
became so essential to the community
that the community restricted any new
construction in this area and I think
reservation of this Courtyard is kind of
fascinating it speaks to our need for
continuity and stability even in an
ever-evolving chaos like Kowloon wall
City it speaks to our natural tendency
to gravitate around any kind of Link to
the Past and how these physical anchors
can become the Bedrock of a community
the Yaman buildings are all the remain
of the city now in 1994 cowlin wall city
was finally demolished and what was once
a chaotic pulsating Hive of human life
has been replaced with a peaceful
Chinese Garden I'm sure it was necessary
but I can't help but feel a kind of
emptiness this raw gritty energetic
Urban anomaly has been sanitized erased
from this world existing only in the
minds of those who live there but
quickly it's Fading Into Distant
Memories into hazy dreams or even
nightmares but there is also a belief
that the essence of a place it's Soul
can transcend a physical dimension
so maybe the spirit of Kowloon wall City
still lingers on
[Music]
foreign
there were some really fantastic books
that we referenced for This research
some were analytical some were kind of
fictional and some were very rated R in
case you're interested in any of these I
will leave the links in the description
we also did a lot of research for this
video a lot of which we had to Translate
from Chinese so if you're interested in
our research booklet we will also leave
that in the description we also have a
newsletter and a Discord server if you
want to stay updated with what we're
doing what do you guys think about this
crazy City let us know in the comments
and with that I'll see you guys in the
next video
thank you